and then the next this guy says you hire
someone less cynical and Chris Hardwick
maybe he could write for a grouchy old
man magazine let's talk about the story
page 74 oh wow you're good of the of the
January issue the headline is diary of a
self-help dropouts and the story was
about you looking into these three
different kind of cults of self-help
time management what were the three
books that you looked at in the store I
looked at why I called my friend gina
trapani who was the editor of lifehacker
which is a like it it's sort of an
aggregator of life improvement stuff
tech employment stuffs it like
simplifying your life through through
technology and the internet and she
recommended never check email in the
morning by Julie Morgenstern and also
the 4-hour workweek but Tim Ferriss and
I actually already had and it was which
is in the article I already had a copy
of getting things done which is sort of
the ultimate like the gauntlet of
getting things but this is like a geek
cult the getting thing getting things
done David Allen's book GTD GTD which is
really i guess like the Citi fied cousin
of Larry the Cable guy's famous mantra
but it is but getting her done get-get
or done getting her Dungey ' chapter one
get her done chapter 2 the end chapter 3
i'm a millionaire so i went through and
trying to live each one of these
programs for two weeks at a time to see
if I could you know maybe extract some
some bits of useful information for for
the freelancer it's like a full embrace
just a full embrace just to really
because I'm always looking at ways to
try to make myself more productive
because it's I'm easily distractible and
how'd it go what happened I'm sorry what
I just think it's I just think it's it's
good to know that if you approach any of
these things there's not going to be one
program that's going to give you the
ultimate answer you sort of need to take
that Bruce Lee approach I think and just
take bits and pieces of
that work and then craft you know and if
you really are interested in
productivity you'll spend the time to do
that you know you'll spend the time to
try to craft a system that really works
well for you but I found that no one
system and there and there was some
crossover in each in each of the books
which I thought at least validated like
oh yeah okay these seems to be these
seem to be some sort of universal themes
that run through the ideas of
productivity well tell me a good story
like tell me one thing will happen with
while you were living the dream here
with these with the time management like
I really tried to never check email in
the morning and I've just failed
miserably it just failed miserably every
morning because I just you just forget
it's just such an easy pattern to get
into you just used to run and check your
email in the morning I failed the most
basic level on that book I did exactly
the opposite of what it is that's the
title it is the title yeah I black blew
it I work well in I found I work well in
hour and a half chunks so I know that
after an hour and a half I get tapped
out after that I need to go take a break
and that's where more Julie more
concerned said yeah you know go do
something that you wouldn't normally do
to sort of clear your head so I took a
nature walk and then I began worshiping
the moon and then I had a blood orgy uh
that's productive though it was
productive and get to that blood orgy
for weeks at least I got something done
in the day I wrote a blog post and then
I slid a goat's throat drank its blood
and then cried to the moon and it was a
montage set to a Sarah McLachlan song
was really pretty and you know who knows
how soon it'll be before i revert to my
old ways of just kind of doing things
and if I feel like doing them as they
come even in this economy I was lucky
enough to you know I was lucky enough to
work a little bit this year so it just
became about how do I juggle you know
those responsibilities and still
maintain some kind of a some kind of a
home life animals to feed I got plans to
hug I gots a McLachlan songs to listen
to